we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is
something a lot of people contacted me
about what exactly is wrong with
Congressman Jim Jordan take a look at
this
hi David how's it going Michael from
Missouri I just got done Washington's
impeachment inquiry videos and what is
wrong with Jim the gymnasium Jordan
I mean seriously what's what's wrong
with that guy I think that someone needs
to get him I don't know maybe a medical
amount of water or something like that
so he says the man seriously needs some
help
he is unhinged and it's interesting so
first of all if you don't understand the
reference to jim nate jim gymnasium
jordan i'm not gonna mention it here
because i'd rather this video not get
demonetized and much like when you talk
about a certain person who was found
dead under suspicious circumstances in
the last few months your video is d
monetized if I told the gymnasium
gymnasium Jordan story the video would
also be d monetized so look up the
gymnasium thing yeah I see Jim Jordan as
an unhinged player on the Republican
side who believes himself to be and it
has tricked a lot of people an incisive
and devastating questioner of the left
of witnesses who are a critical of
Donald Trump and his behavior is not
just bizarre it's downright wacky and
you can see this in any number of recent
hearings his physical appearance
contributes to that and I don't know if
that that it should or should not be
considered but his physical demeanor and
appearance also just makes him seem
completely out of control and
fortunately he has a cult following on
the right but he's not really making
much of an impact his attempts recently
at least in the impeachment hearings to
try to derail the testimony have have
fortunately not worked so continue
keeping an eye on him including this
week during the impeachment hearings
remember on Black Friday we will be
sending out an email to everybody on our
newsletter with a massive David Pakman
show membership special this is the last
membership drive of the year if you've
been thinking of becoming a member but
you are waiting for a suite discount and
get on our newsletter by signing up at
david pakman
common than on Black Friday next Friday
you will be emailed with a super secret
one-time use coupon code that you can
use to get a massive Bigley tremendous
discount off of membership we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
truck talk by the way about a prison
worker related to that person who died
connected to Trump suspiciously a few
months ago we will talk about that we
will talk about Trump pardoning to
servicemembers accused of war crimes and
we will also talk about a very strange
situation in while involving White
Castle and the suspension of three
judges all of those stories and a
possible upcoming chess battle at the
David Pakman show on today's bonus show
become a member or a patron to get
instant access